all right welcome my name's Kip shower
I'm from Denver Colorado over in the
United States how many people have been
to Colorado before one all right - all
right three
well great you're all welcome to come to
Colorado sometime and come enjoy the
skiing or the nice weather we have I've
really enjoyed my trip to Milan this was
the first time I've ever been here I've
been to Rome and Florence and Venice
before so thanks so much for having me
over here so we'll spend the next thirty
five minutes and I'm gonna save a little
time for questions at the end talking
about Google's media story so median
entertainment I was hired three months
ago by Google I spent the last ten years
at espera how many people use espera if
you're in the media and entertainment
world moving large files okay most
people would
[Music]
so then IBM acquired espera but so for
the last three years I was over it at
IBM also so today we're gonna talk about
media Google's strategy in the media and
then we're gonna dig into the online
platform called ambato as well as the
machine learning you might have already
gone to a few sessions on machine
learning and I'll talk to you about how
we're gonna be applying it in the media
and entertainment space so a little
background everybody knows that media
consumption is changing obviously on my
phone here I can launch an application
watch video content right here how many
people were watching video right before
they started this just about everybody
right I read a statistic that every
single day 57% of people watch video on
their phone and my question to that was
what are the other 43% of the people
doing with their phone if you're not
watching video right I mean everybody
watches video today you and some of the
videos even just start to play right
away so if you're watching YouTube or
Facebook or ESPN or any of your sporting
channels you know the videos will just
start to play so the idea is how do you
make sure you get the right video
content to each of us and you have to be
able to get it anytime to any different
device I've got two teenage boys and to
get them to sit down and watch a TV show
I don't remember the last time they did
if it was I'm sure it was just a movie
that was recorded one of my son's has
built this big computer with two
different monitors and I don't know if
he has a split brain or something but
one he keeps YouTube and video channels
up so he can be watching TV while he's
usually playing a game or you know doing
his homework or something like that so
the way we're consuming content has
changed dramatically and then the other
thing for for you take somebody like my
son is how did he get to the content
that he wants to watch so he's into
paintball I don't know if they have
paintball here but you run around and
shoot each other with paintball guns
and there's actually a league in the in
North America so it there's a
professional group of paintballers in
North America and they have a
championship game and you can actually
pay a company that videoed livestreams
it like $5 a month to be able to watch
those games I mean you start to think
about that and what it opens up for the
possibility of everybody is being able
to watch video live video live streaming
video for whatever hobby or interest or
yeah you know special concept that we
have out there
and be able to consume it yet you know
on my phone while I'm at a conference be
able to watch it at home potentially on
a TV or you know on your computer have
two different yeah you know monitors go
in and you can consume the content so
everybody that's in the median
entertainment world you know that the
trick is getting it to every device now
so then the next step is how do I use
data to drive what contents being pushed
and how do I personalize it so that we
each are consuming you know the video
content that we want house of cards if
I'm not sure how popular that show was
over here it was a Netflix show but they
used data to figure out who was gonna
watch it the series before they launched
it by running different types of
trailers and testing them getting all
that data back analyzing it and then it
helped them launch house of cards and it
became a very very popular show a couple
of the other things that are interesting
the amount of content now that's
available is how do i how do I get my
content seen if I'm on the other side
trying to produce the content there's
over 400 hours of video uploaded to
YouTube every minute so just massive
massive amounts of content being
uploaded and then with machine learning
coming out people are thinking well or
machine learning a little bit but also
reality TV and the YouTube type content
or Facebook type content that's all
reality I know a few years ago everybody
was thinking that TV shows that are
scripted that have actors and actresses
we're gonna gonna go away and and the
world was just going to evolve into
reality TV what's happened is actually
the complete opposite where today
there's over four hundred and fifty-five
scripted TV shows that's over double
what we had just five years ago I was
down in Los Angeles two weeks ago
and in Los Angeles that's where a lot of
the sap they call them soundstages where
they actually shoot the TV shows and and
film them and right now every single
soundstage is full
if both on the universal lot Disney Fox
they're renting them out because there's
so much new content being produced and
the reason is is because you can get
that to every one of your consumers
without just having to go through one of
the big channels to distribute your
content so it's exciting Am I
in my eyes this is exciting because it
means there's new content better content
more targeted content and it allows us
to personalize the content that that's
being created and get that to the
consumer I'm not gonna spend much time
on this because I'm sure you've already
attended you know some of the other
seminars but the investment in Google's
cloud is amazing for video customers
content distribution networks are
critical being able to stream your video
and have a quick user experience are
absolutely imperative to getting good
quality video so today you can use yeah
you know Akamai there's limelight level
3 fastly there's quite a few content
distribution networks available and
Google last year opened up the CDN that
YouTube runs on so the performance that
you get on YouTube the scalability of
YouTube is now available so for a video
content publisher you're gonna have
another option of a content distribution
network it's mainly been internally
consumed by the YouTube team so it might
not have all the bells and whistles
right now that you would expect if
you're used to a commercially facing
content distribution network but it's
definitely ramping up quickly so if
you're in if you're using a content
distribution network today you're
looking at moving over to Google you'll
want to look at Google as a possible CDN
provider for your video content
obviously I think everybody heard in the
keynote we have the applications that
run over a billion users so that brings
us back to median entertainment where's
it where's our focus so in in kind of
step one we have customers that just
want to lift and shift their
applications over to the cloud over
there you might be using just the
compute environment you might be using
the storage environment as well as the
content distribution network
so this morning I met with a customer
they thought that they wanted to run on
top of our video streaming platform but
it really turned out they had already
built everything they needed and they
were just gonna need to lift and shift
it up over onto the infrastructure
platform so when you're working through
media and entertainment challenges
you'll find that oftentimes you've
already have what you what you've
already built might move over onto the
cloud pretty easily and then just be
able to take advantage of you know the
different CDN options so we can
definitely help you move your your
applications over to the cloud then in
the middle basic over-the-top apps so
Google acquired a company called ambato
and I'll talk at a deeper level on
ambato back in July that can provide you
an end-to-end over-the-top solution so
if you're looking at launching your own
application and you need video content
in there we'll go over that
re-engineering the workflow so if you
have a workflow where you might be able
to scale it up quicker if you're running
on the cloud we have people that can
help you you know figure out how do I
move it over to the cloud and then be
able to scale it up and then the third
area that we're that's obviously
receiving a lot of attention is the
machine learning and how are we going to
apply it into our video products or how
can you take that video intelligence API
and apply it to your own content so
these are kind of the three areas that
we're really focusing on
from a Google perspective on the media
and entertainment market so Google's
commitment to the media and
entertainment market I I had been in the
media and entertainment market for the
last ten years obviously you know that
Google's YouTube and you kind of think
of that but they've acquired a product
called zinc in the rendering engine and
they also support many of the largest
companies doing the big animated movies
ambato is a over-the-top broadcasting
solution and I'm going quick on this
because I have additional slides on them
intelligence you know we're just
starting the Intelligence phase that's
definitely in my opinion we're at the
ground level and and customers like you
are gonna help define the best ways to
use this technology monetization so if
you're playing back to your videos and
you can add the ads in there obviously
that's how you're gonna start to make
money and then Google acquired a company
called Widevine wide buys is one of the
DRM solutions so there's about three
different digital write management
solutions out there Google owns Widevine
YouTube chrome obviously so this is kind
of our 360 degree view of median
entertainment so really quick for
anybody that's into 3d rendering out
there we have an application so if
you're using maya or cinema 4d Houdini
or nuke those are applications that look
like this that allow you to create 3d
models we have created a plugin and you
can't really read this through the
projector but it's the coolest quick way
to use the cloud so when you finished
your model and you've done all your
coloring and all your frames and all
your rendering there's a pulldown menu
right here that tells you your options
for cloud rendering and it gives you how
many compute cores are there and then
you literally just type in a number for
the number of computers you want to have
spun up in the cloud and it'll tell you
your cost
right there we took care of all the
rendering costs on the back end so you
don't have to have special rendering
engines and when you hit go it will
package all your content up send it up
to the cloud do your full render and
then bring it back down
so the Jungle Book was done by a company
called MPC and they used the Google
render cloud they did not use ink
because they have their own big custom
workflow for rendering but the the
amount of compute to do some of these
very very high-end render rendering
projects is kind of mind-boggling but 41
years of compute time they were able to
do and over in just on just over two
months so what does this allow the
artists and the animation you know team
that's working on it it gives them more
time it allows them to spend you know
more time working on the fine details
and just continually iterating on the on
the product so that they can deliver a
better product to us so that's the power
of the cloud around rendering so anybody
that's in the rendering portion of media
and entertainment definitely find your
local Google yeah you know sales person
we have worked with all the major
studios we have what's called MPAA
certification so the major studios have
approved the Google Cloud so some really
amazing stuff we're doing in the
rendering area of it so now I'll switch
gears into an Bato and borrows the
company they acquire a Google acquired
back in July and it's designed to be
sort of an end-to-end over-the-top
workflow to help you if you're putting
video on your application you know like
at the beginning of the you know show if
if you're pulling up your sports
application and you need to stream your
video or if you're to built developing
to be able to stream to say over
chromecast
or an Apple TV and you need to be able
to play your video content back on any
of those formats and Bato will be able
to help you some of the customers NBC is
the largest broadcaster in North America
and that's one of our big customers
Univision's latin america one of their
largest broadcasters ambato was masive
it was north america only so we're
starting to work with european customers
now that we have the support of google
and have been able to expand the team so
we can definitely support you we can set
up web meetings if you need to on ambato
so what does ambato do again sort of the
complete end-to-end workflow and I'll
dive into each little section of it and
we'll go through each one so live
streaming so in so you always have to
have some sort of hardware to be able to
capture the video signal but it's a
software based encoding engine and you
can deploy it either on premise where
the cameras are and then move the data
to the cloud or you can just deploy it
in the cloud and you can capture either
what's called baseband video coming
directly out of the camera or you can
bring in a previously encoded signal for
a live transcode so what does it look
like over there's where you're capturing
your content you're bringing it in
through the mbot oh and it's just a
commodity hardware device running our
software and then you can go straight to
a content distribution network so the
CDN and then you can stream out either
an HLS format and we're now releasing -
if you're familiar with - it's another
option for streaming video and then the
ads all tie into it but I'll talk about
that in a second if you want if you have
a third-party encoder already meaning
you're your encoding your video already
and you want to send it to the cloud so
that we can transcode it into all the
different flavors and then deliver it
out over your CDN we can run in the
cloud also so you really have two
options for all the for the
way you run the ambato software so when
that live signal and what I'm talking
live I mean you know we're watching a
newscast or a sporting event ambato
actually broadcast the Superbowl back in
2014 so millions of millions of people
watching the same video that's the power
of ambato but then live to bod means so
that live signals coming in I'm gonna
capture it and by capturing it I can
then use that to post it out onto social
networks I can push it to other online
sites so being able to capture it as
it's being broadcast will save you a
step you don't have to wait until the
broadcast is over and then have somebody
transfer it to you you can capture it
right away so then people say well as
it's going along I might need to cut out
advertisements because sometimes you
can't advertise what's going out over
air on your phone or on your mobile
devices so you might need to change the
advertisement so there's a cloud editing
tool that makes it really really easy to
cut ads out and then you can also
quickly grab little snippets of
highlights and you could use that to
post it on to you know YouTube Facebook
Twitter and start to send little bits of
your video out to your social media
quickly so this is the architecture it
looks exactly the same as before it's
just now you're doing your your capture
and your editing in the cloud as you
receive the content and then you can
also send content out to the premium
syndicators so over here like sky and
all the big broadcasters here that need
to receive your content we have over a
hundred and forty-one profiles set up
worldwide to receive the content because
even North American broadcasters send
the content worldwide so those are
already set up there automated and makes
it easy getting the content out so video
encoding so once I have this video and I
need to get it into all the different
format strands
we take care of all of that whether
you're doing the set-top delivery you
know or going to a chromecast or going
to your phone we can take care of that
we can also work with video overlays
embedding the captions putting in at the
bottom there what are called sketti
markers those are the markers is the
video contents going along that'll
trigger ads to be played so when it's
creating the videos so that it plays it
out we take into account kind of
everything you need to do with that
video and make sure it's ready to go so
they you can send it out through your
content distribution network syndication
so syndication I already mentioned it
just a second ago but this is taking the
content now that you have and sending it
out to all the online players that need
to receive your content so that then
somebody that's subscribing maybe to a
Hulu or even Netflix right that you need
your movies up there so you send it up
to them and then they they'll be able to
play it there so we syndicator 1.5
million minutes a month for on behalf of
the customers that use our content and
that's going to all the leading portals
around the world so we have an OTT store
this is not just yeah you know we're
gonna build a store where you can do
quick subscriptions it's more tying into
applications where you need to like
authenticate against the cable
subscription so so if you're a sports
app and you need to make sure that
somebody is paying for a cable
subscription like with the TV Everywhere
this will help you tie your application
together with a subscription service and
then dynamic ad insertion so ad
insertion at the server side is what i'm
Bato does there's obviously client-side
ad insertion but to plug it into the
server side you can do it right within
the ambadas stack so again you can put
ads on Apple TV chromecast Roku any bath
VA st compliant third party ad server so
the double-click server there's other
servers out there
like freewheel we can pull for many of
those ad servers and then generating the
analytics is obviously key getting the
feedback for what ads are playing and
the completion and the click-through
rates so the one thing with server-side
ads I like to point out is it's a little
smoother user experience because it's
not getting they're having to go grab
the app pull it back in so when you're
playing video the server side out
insertion it's already baked into the
video stream and it'll just play right
out so then the player itself and bada
won't make a player that the actual skin
that's up to you and your developers to
make it look and brand it however you
want but what an embody players the
backend SDKs and the API is that you're
going to use will allow you to have that
player and be able to play it on any
device it does really fast startup and
it'll insert the ads we've talked about
it does both adaptive bitrate streaming
and it can do virtual reality you know
VR stream so if you're gonna develop
your player we give you all the backend
tools that you need to be able to pull
the content play the content you just
need to develop the application and use
our API and then there's a reporting
dashboard there's a few changes going on
with the reporting now that we're part
of Google Google obviously is very
concerned about what data is being
collected so ambadas just lining up with
the Google Analytics team and making
sure the feedback that we get within the
ambato platform matches up with the
feedback that Google collects so a great
reporting engine as part of it so a
couple examples right so that's the
stack that's the wheel but what are a
few things you can do with it so by
being able to migrate off of a satellite
truck going up over satellite hitting
the data center going to the service
bureaus and then back out you can now
from go from the cloud you have your
encoder either on-site or in the in the
cloud
you send the livestream there you stream
it out to all the devices you can then
syndicate it from the cloud so all of a
sudden your costs of the truck and the
satellite you don't need that anymore
the real key though that I've found is
making sure you have enough bandwidth
you know between the venue and getting
to the cloud and and over the last two
years almost every venue has been
putting in more and more bandwidth which
is going to allow this to occur kind of
anywhere is what I'm seeing so big cost
savings if you're if you're broadcasting
content looking to move it over into the
cloud and then a live linear Channel so
if you're broadcasting all day you need
to have a schedule right and we create a
schedule so the schedule because you're
not with digital rights you're not
always gonna be able to broadcast on
your phone or out over the top the same
content that you're sending across onto
the TV so you can quickly replace
content that you don't have the rights
to that you want to have the rights to
or with a different show that you have
the rights to so it's they're quick easy
adaptable you know live linear streaming
programming that is also part of in Bato
and then this is where it's kind of
exciting what's coming around machine
learning because now if I can
personalize this with a pool of content
then everybody could start to get their
own shows and it's not just one show
going out to everybody using the same
application so this is one of the areas
that I think is gonna benefit greatly
from machine learning and being able to
take all the feedback from people that
are watching your channels and be able
to provide different content to them so
shifting gears from Envato virtual
reality is an area that Google's
invested in heavily for anybody that
at NAB which is the big trade show in
Las Vegas back in April Google will have
a booth at IBC over in Amsterdam I'm
guessing a lot of people here go to IBC
so we'll be back at IBC but this camera
was at NAB it's really cool it's about
that big you take the picture and then
we don't build the camera but what
Google does is they built the software
it's called jump that allows you to
upload
I think there's 34 cameras and upload
all the content and then it does the
stitching so if you're in VR you can do
that and then anybody that saw the
release the other day Google announced
BR like 180 instead of BR 360 because
360 you know allows you to look all the
way around but with if you look back
there and you have a lot of cameras
shooting the content all of a sudden you
see everybody making the movie or making
the content with 180 you can look around
this way but you're only seeing what the
movie makers want you to see so I think
it's yeah you know Google I I haven't
this is just from what I read but I
think it's a way of trying to say you
know what let's adopt a technology that
is really cool in terms of being able to
pan around in the video but not allow
you to go back and see you know how it
was being made so VR 180 just was
announced a couple days ago and I'm sure
cameras like this will figure out ways
to you know upload it to jump and then
just render the front half of it
daydream so so the goggles so that you
can look at the VR experience these are
the goggles that Google creates and then
kind of off of products back to the core
cloud that I think is probably the most
interesting part if you if you kind of
have built already everything that that
yeah you know I've showed you today
bigquery the cloud-based analytics so as
we start to run machine learning against
the back the archives of all the video
that we own and we start to pull out
metadata more meta
more metadata if you can get it into
bigquery and then start to be able to
run analytics on it I think that's gonna
be where the power is combining the
machine learning with the analytics and
being able to pull out you know queries
of you know I need video with this actor
or this actress in here over the last
five years and be able to quickly pull
all that content out and and create new
content with it so bigquery is our yeah
you know Enterprise warehouse for this
large data Spotify uses it I think
you've probably seen this in some other
presentations but the reason I like to
point it out from a media and
entertainment perspective is sometimes
you're asking simple questions one of
the questions I read about online in
terms of Spotify was what are just the
top ten songs that played in Spain for
October and it was taking him 44 minutes
to get the answer back on that when they
moved over into bigquery that timeframe
went down to a minute so then you think
about the business analysts trying to
decide what are we gonna advertise in
Spain what are we gonna do you know for
the next month if they can ask more
questions of the data and get the
responses back quicker obviously it's
really gonna help so so bigquery as that
platform layer that I think is gonna
help media and entertainment customers
but it's part of the the basic cloud not
you know not an add-on like ambato that
was acquired so what's the next wave
machine learning we've all been talking
about machine learning and so everybody
I think is seeing that there's the five
api's that are available today so the
speech ones working on grabbing that
text out for closed captioning and then
taking that closed captioning turning
that into metadata that you can search
and then also translating it into all
the different languages is obviously a
big focus and then the cloud video
intelligence API is gonna be used quite
a bit
so what we did is we took the video
supply chain here and came up with a few
of the concepts that we're working on to
plug into ambato so today they're the
machine learning is not built in Dan
bottle yet but this is what we're
working on for future versions of the
OTT so a couple that I like to highlight
like in cloud editing I I hope machine
learning doesn't replace all the jobs
you know and that it allows us to
display more content kind of back to my
first first comments which is there's
more content available because there's
more ways to consume it and I can see
exactly what I want so I was down at
NASCAR the race one of the race series
in in the US but basically think about
Formula one over here if your favorite
driver or favorite car doesn't come in
in the top three or so of that day more
than likely if you log on that night and
you didn't watch the race there's almost
no content available to watch right
because somebody took all the video that
was shot that day and made a couple
really cool highlights of the race but
that means you know my favorite driver I
can't see any content about oh but every
one of those cars has video cameras on
it right one probably on the driver now
usually one facing forward camera facing
backwards so it's not that we didn't
capture the content it's that we didn't
have enough editors to go around to edit
every single one we're imagine if you
could bring all that content in right at
the end of a race run it through a
machine learning kind of a cloud editing
intelligent clipping so it was very
quick and for every single race car you
could produce a five-minute clip of the
races well the that's a lot because as
editing you would have to spend a lot of
time looking but if you can train
on what's interesting when it made
passes you know when it went into the
pit stops all the things that you might
want to see about the race imagine you
could then have forty let's say there's
forty cars in a race forty different
clips maybe you could charge people a
small subscription to go in and be able
to view all the clips at the end of my
favorite driver right so I could clip on
it watch the video pay a little bit or
it's ad-supported maybe there's ads and
now instead of everybody just watching
one highlight everybody can go and pick
and choose which highlight they want to
watch because that's the driver they're
interested in and more than likely
they're also gonna still go watch the
highlights of the overall race because
of course we want to see who can can
race so these are the things in my mind
that I get excited about because all of
a sudden there's more content available
easier to get to it it's edited it's
gone through and created better
highlights so that's in my mind a kind
of forward customer facing
implementation of machine learning under
the end coding if we can do a better job
with encoding as the machine learns so
if I'm an announcer and I'm just
standing here like I am here encoding
you should be able to squeeze this video
down pretty far because there's not much
action but as soon as action starts slow
down the encoding so you get a better
quality signal so I think on sporting
events or events that switch from almost
no action to a lot of action if you can
have machines watching that and being
able to encode up and down on the fly
we're gonna get better compression and
then there's a whole host of other ways
we're looking at plugging in the machine
learning so again the vision cloud
vision you might have seen this so on
stills you know face detection pulling
that out the logo identification labels
landmark OCR and then this was on my
highlights example this is also like
chopped is a movie
chef's movie or a TV show over in the US
but being able to take machine learning
feed it full of clips over you know the
hour put them in and say give me a
five-minute highlight for four chopped
there's some shows discovery they shoot
up in Alaska the crab fishermen are out
there I think I've heard they shoot like
five hundred hours or a thousand hours
of content for every show because they
have so many boats going out and being
able to run it through machine learning
and be able to help create more
personalized highlights is gonna
definitely be a use case for machine
learning and then the one that
everybody's still trying to figure out
and and how to do a better job is
contextual ads and micro segments
tagging those videos using machine
learning so you know whatever's playing
in the video
can you pull out related content out of
the video specifically and and with
these vision api's we're gonna be able
to do that so the last one the the
closed captioning I talked about a
little bit so being able to take the
speech-to-text and then be able to turn
that into metadata so that you can
search the text and be able to to find
the content that you want so machine
learning it's definitely if in its
infancy right now in this industry
those api's are available today there's
some good tutorials on it if you want to
start to learn about them and then if
you're interested in like the ambato
software or the Zink software definitely
contact your local google rep they can
get in touch with us we can do meetings
with you and help you out there so with
that I've got a few minutes for
questions thanks so much for your time
any any questions does anybody speak
English I hope you do so I'll be I'll be
back here if there aren't any questions
but thanks so much for your time and
enjoy the rest of Google Mex
[Applause]